This cat better watch out. And the only
thing more badass than guns
is kittens.
It's episode 33 of IMG!
This is every way
Mario can die on one page.
And this is a Hadouken manicure.
Could you grab me some peanut butter?
Oh, but watch out for the honey.
Shaving cream.
But the best type of spill? Cat face.
Look how happy it made this guy.
What? Ohhhh.
Banana dog. Better than a heart butt.
And spot the difference.
Here's Lady Gaga drinking tea. Some guys
really, really like this and thus
hotgirlsdrinkingtea.tumblr.com.
Enjoy.
Remember the Big Bad Wolf?
Well, here's what he should
have done. Do you guys accept Batman & Joker
money? Well, look how well I throw a hammer.
Oh.
The great outdoors
with a body.
And the great outdoors with a face.
But let's get trippier with GIFs.
Some are hypnotizingly
patriotic and others use rapidly reversing
colors to perpetually move
towards you.
This one too.
If you've got red-cyan 3D glasses, take look at these
worms.
Just do it. Some just
did it. But now let's lay down with stuffed
animal versions of ourselves and enjoy
two montages
in one video.
Photobombs are great but this one is
currently my favorite. "Hi!"
Let's hold hands, I want to keep you safe.
Uh, just kidding.
Going for the dunk?
Wait, wait, wait. You got a booger there.
And you know what? Lots of guys get caught staring.
John Kerry, even Obama.
Sometimes it's sneaky,
sometimes it's surprising and sometimes
it's just judgmental.
On Facebook.com/VsauceGaming Anton
showed me that Sponge Bob
is made out of sadness.
Stephanie introduced a keyboard shaped
waffle maker and Krishna showed as a dog
that can make things float
and terrify people.
Now it's time to watch
LÜT on our other channel, Vsauce2.
Vsauce2 is just like Vsauce,
except we get to be a little bit more
specific over there.
Now, if you're not subscribed to us
because you don't have a YouTube
account,
make today be the first day of the rest of your life.
Create a
YouTube account.
It's free and it feels wonderful.
With an account you can subscribe to us
and know exactly when we put new stuff out.
And you can favorite our videos so that
you never lose that link to a flash game in DONG! that you don't wanna lose.
If you don't have a YouTube account yet
and you create your first one today
and subscribe to us, let us know in the
comments below, so that we can all
thank you for making the world a better
place and tell you personally:
As always,
thanks for watching.